O
TEST NEGATIVE.
TRACE.
>> Trace: RICH EDSON TRAVELING
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, EDUCATION
SECRETARY MIGUEL CARDONA,
WELCOME TO "FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
>> Secretary Cardona:
THANK YOU, TRACE, HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
>> Trace: HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
YOU AS WELL, SIR.
IN AN EFFORT TO CONTINUE THE
SCHOOL YEAR WITH IN PERSON
LEARNING, THE CDC RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THAT STUDENTS EXPOSED
TO THE VIRUS CAN SAFELY CONTINUE
IN PERSON LEARNING SO LONG AS
THEY ARE REGULARLY TESTED FOR
THE VIRUS, BUT NOW ACCORDING TO
BURBERRY OH, AFFIRMS THE SCHOOL
CLOSURES, THE CLOSURES ARE
REALLY TICKING BACK UP, ALREADY
MORE THAN 2100 SCHOOLS PLANNED
TO BE CLOSED IN THE COMING WEEK.
MR. SECRETARY, WHERE ARE WE
HEADING EXACTLY?
>> Secretary Cardona: YOU
KNOW, WE'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR, OUR
EXPECTATION IS FOR SCHOOLS TO BE
OPEN FULL-TIME FOR STUDENTS FOR
IN PERSON LEARNING.
WE REMEMBER THE IMPACT OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES ON STUDENTS LAST YEAR
AND OUR SCIENCE IS BETTER, WE
HAVE BETTER TOOLS, WE HAVE
$10 BILLION IN THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FOR SURVEILLANCE
TESTING.
OF VACCINATIONS ARE AVAILABLE
NOW FOR CHILDREN AGES FIVE AND
UP.
WE RECOGNIZE THERE MAY BE SOME
BUMPS IN THE ROAD, ESPECIALLY IN
THE NEXT WEEK WERE
SUPERINTENDENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE GETTING CALLS THAT
SOME OF SCHOOLS MAY HAVE 5-10%
OF THEIR STAFF UNAVAILABLE SO
ANY DECISIONS ON VERY SHORT-TERM
OR EMERGENCY CLOSURES ARE MOST
LIKELY BASED OFF OF STAFFING
ISSUES AND ULTIMATELY THOSE ARE
SAFETY ISSUES WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE ADEQUATE STAFF, BUT THE
GOAL IS FULL TIME IN PERSON
LEARNING.
>> Trace: YOU MENTION BUMPS ON
THE ROAD, THOSE SCHOOLS THAT
PLAN TO REMAIN OPEN, INCLUDING
LARGER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
NEW YORK CITY, LOS ANGELES, AND
D.C., HAVE ANNOUNCED STRATEGIES
CENTERED VERY MUCH ON TESTING TO
STAY AHEAD OF THE SPREAD AND
KEEP IN PERSON LEARNING, BUT
MR. SECRETARY, HOW PRACTICAL, IN
YOUR ESTIMATION, IS THE TESTING
CENTERED APPROACH WHEN THERE IS
A NATIONWIDE TESTING SHORTAGE,
FEDERAL DISTRIBUTION REALLY
STILL UP IN THE AIR, AND NEW
RESEARCH NOW SHOWING THAT IT'S
QUESTIONING THE RELIABILITY OF
DETECTING OMICRON BY THE WIDELY
USED RAPID TEST, SO HOW DO YOUS?
>> Secretary Cardona: RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, WE KNOW TESTING IS A
PART OF OVERALL STRATEGY THAT
SHOULD BE USED TO KEEP OUR
SCHOOLS OPEN.
VACCINATION EFFORTS ARE ALSO A
BIG PART OF THAT STRATEGY, AND
WE'VE SEEN THEM WORK.
I WOULD SAY THAT AS SCHOOLS COME
IN, THEY SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT A TESTING STRATEGY TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF STUDENTS ARE
SYMPTOMS, THEY CAN BE TESTED IN
SCHOOL.
KEEPING THEM IN SCHOOL IS
CRITICAL FOR THEM, FOR A
COMMUNITY, FOR OUR COMMUNITIES,
FOR OUR PARENTS.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
TESTING -- INCREASING
VACCINATION HELPS.
ADHERENCE TO THE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES THAT WE KNOW WORK ARE
ALSO PART OF THE STRATEGY.
>> Trace: WHAT ABOUT THE
SCHOOL'S ABILITY TO CARRY OUT
THESE PRESCRIPTIONS, THIS
STRATEGY TALK ABOUT?
YOU KNOW, WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
WHAT IN THE NEUROMA STRAIN THE
PANDEMIC HAS PUT ON THE SYSTEM
IN THE TERMS OF STAFFING
SHORTAGES.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS OF THE
FOLLOWING.
"I AM CONCERNED THAT LOTS OF
DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR TESTING AND
TESTS TO STAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY, REALLY
BUMPY AND THERE'S GOING TO NEED
A LOT OF GRACE, AND I THINK A
CHRISTIAN IS THAT FRUSTRATIONS
ARE HIGH AND GRACE, AMONG A LOT
OF PARENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
IS IN SHORT SUPPLY," SIR.
>> Secretary Cardona: THERE'S
A LEVEL OF URGENCY THAT WE
SHOULDN'T LOSE AROUND MAKING
SURE THAT HER CHILDREN LEARN IN
PERSON.
THE IMPACT OF HYBRID LEARNING
I'M OF THE IMPACT OF REMOTE
LEARNING, IS VERY REAL FOR US
PARENTS WHO HAVE HAD TO
EXPERIENCE IT AT HOME AS WELL.
SO WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER, WHICH INCLUDES
GETTING ACCESS TO THOSE TESTS.
LET ME REMIND YOU, THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN, WHEN IT CAME OUT IN
MARCH, HAD FUNDING FOR TESTING
AND ANKS TO GROUPS LIKE THE
ROCKEFELLER FOUNDATION,
CONTRACTS WERE SET UP EARLY FOR
SCHOOLS TO HAVE SURVEILLANCE
TESTING REGULARLY DONE IN THEIR
SCHOOLS.
WE SEE MORE AND MORE OF THAT
HAPPENING AT OUR EFFORTS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ARE TO
SUPPORT DISTRICTS AND STATES TO
GET CONTRACTS SET UP SO THAT
THESE SYSTEMS ARE ROBUST, SO
THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN STAY IN
THE CLASSROOMS.
>> Trace: ARE USING THE ROAD
IS NOT GOING TO BE AS BUMPY AS
SHE SAYS IT IS?
>> Secretary Cardona: I'LL
TELL YOU, I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE MARCH, 2020, AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER.
I DO THINK THERE WILL BE BUMPS
ON THE ROAD, ESPECIALLY
TOMORROW.
SUPERINTENDENTS TODAY ARE
RECEIVING CALLS OF STAFF MEMBERS
THAT THEY WERE EXPECTING TO BE
IN THE CLASSROOM TOMORROW WHO
HAVE COME DOWN WITH COVID, SO WE
ARE GOING TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES, ALL HANDS ON DECK,
LET'S KEEP OUR CHILDREN IN THE
CLASSROOM, THAT SHOULD BE OUR
DEFAULT, THINKING, AND AS
PROBLEMS COME UP, WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SOLVE THEM.
>> Trace: I WANT TO RUN SOME
NUMBERS BY YOU.
DECEMBER'S ON INCREASE OF 50% IN
NEW PEDIATRIC COVID CASES,
THAT'S ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS,
AND WENT ON TO SAY ONLY 23% OF
5-11-YEAR-OLDS HAVE RECEIVED ONE
DOSE OF VACCINE.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT THE
SCHOOLS, EVEN AFTER THEIR BEST
EFFORTS TO REMAIN OPEN FOR IN
PERSON LEARNING, HAVE A PLAN B
JUST IN CASE OF THINGS LIKE YOU
SAID, STAFFING SHORTAGES OR
PARENTS DECIDING TO KEEP MORE
AND MORE OF THEIR STUDENTS HOME
TO
>> Secretary Cardona: WE
LEARNED THAT EDUCATORS WERE ABLE
TO TURN ON A DIME WHEN PANDEMIC
CAME AND WE MOVED TO REMOTE
LEARNING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT WASN'T IDEAL BUT WE KNOW THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO ADAPT.
THE GOAL HOWEVER REMAINS TO STAY
FOCUSED ON IN PERSON LEARNING
NOT ONLY FOR OUR STUDENTS'
ACADEMIC NEEDS BUT FOR THEIR
SOCIAL, EMOTIONAL NEEDS.
MANY PARENTS DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY OF STAYING HOME SO WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO KEEP THEM IN SCHOOL AS OUR
PLAN A, PLAN B, AND PLAN C.
OBVIOUSLY IF SHORT-TERM
EMERGENCY CLOSURES ARE
NECESSARY, SCHOOLS SHOULD HAVE
THE TOOLS BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE AN
EDUCATION THAT WAY BUT THAT
SHOULD BE THE EXCEPTION, NOT THE
ROLE.
>> Trace: YOU TALK ABOUT
PLAN B.
AT ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
ALREADY HAD TO MODIFY PLANS TO
REQUIRE VACCINATION OF STUDENTS
12 AND OVER, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE LOANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT, PULL BACK ITS MANDATE
OF THE LAST MINUTE WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
IMMUNITY ACTIVISTS QUESTIONED A
PERHAPS-UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE,
MEANING THAT MORE THAN 30,000
UNVACCINATED STUDENTS WOULD BE
MOVED BACK INTO DISTANCE
LEARNING.
THE DISTRICT DEFENDED THE
TURNABOUT IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT HAVE A PLAN B TO
STAND UP REMOTE LEARNING
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE LAST
MINUTE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT,
SIR?
>> Secretary Cardona: YOU
KNOW, I'VE ALWAYS SAID
VACCINATION DECISIONS NEED TO BE
MADE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND AT
THE STATE LEVEL, BUT WE KNOW
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF IN
THOSE PLACES WHERE VACCINATION
NUMBERS ARE HIGH, THERE'S LESS
DISRUPTION.
THERE ARE LESS STUDENTS IN A
HOSPITAL, SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE
PUSHING EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO VACCINES FOR OUR
CHILDREN, VACCINATION CLINICS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
HAPPENING.
WE NEED TO PROTECT HER STUDENTS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE WANT
ALL OF HER STUDENTS BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM, BUT WE WANT TO DO IT
SAFELY.
>> Trace: WE TALKED ABOUT THE
GRACE AMONG PARENTS, THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTION, WHICH HAS
SURVEYED PARENTS FOUR TIMES
DURING THE PANDEMIC, FOUND THAT
PARENTAL CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN'S WELL-BEING HAD BIG
DONE TO EASE DURING THE SUMMER,
CONTINUED TO EASE IN OCTOBER
WHEN 93% OF STUDENTS WERE IN
PERSON SCHOOL.
BROOKINGS WROTE THE FOLLOWING,
QUOTING HERE, "THIS EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT THE RELATIVE
NORMALCY OF IN PERSON LEARNING
THIS YEAR MAY BE DRIVING REDUCED
PARENTAL CONCERNS.
AND OF COURSE, AS YOU KNOW,
CLOSURES AND SCHOOL CURRICULUMS
BEGIN HOT BUTTON TOPICS IN THE
ELECTION FOR VIRGINIA GOVERNOR,
FORMER EDUCATION SECRETARY BILL
BENNETT SAID THIS IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH FOX THIS WEEK,
WATCH.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SAYING WE ARE NOT TAKING THIS
ANYMORE, WE DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
>> Trace: MR. SECRETARY, HOW
DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> Secretary Cardona: YOU
KNOW, IN MY TRAVELS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY OVER THE LAST EIGHT,
NINE MONTHS, I'VE TALKED TO
PARENTS, AND THEY WANT THEIR
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL, THEY WANT
THEIR CHILDREN SAFE, AND THEY
WANT TO BE HEARD.
APPEARANCE OF PUT UP A LOT OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF TRYING
TO BALANCE WORK AND EDUCATING
THE CHILDREN, SO THIS
PARTNERSHIP WITH PARENTS NEEDS
TO CONTINUE.
I WANT TO SEE IT ELEVATED AS WE
MOVE FORWARD PAST THE PANDEMIC
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
CHILDREN ARE IN THE CLASSROOM
AND THAT THEY ARE SAFE.
>> Trace: AND PARENTS HAVE
BEEN JUGGLING.